when they raided your house you got the
call while we're making another gun
video yeah
and then they got the call from my mum
that the police were there searching for
the gun and I was like she was like can
you come home and I was like no I'm
filming a video with a gun at the moment
yeah back to you and she was like she
thought it was because of the current
video I was filming it was so funny that
yeah the best thing was the police
arrived at the door they asked my mum uh
they'll just like oh we're here because
the video Alex has made and then my mum
just starts listing the videos
like nope nope nope yeah it's that way
though she's like yeah
those police played it so well because
they were kind of like uh someone for
your mum to vent to like they they're
like my crazy son is always
yeah yeah and I told her as well I was
like mum you don't have to tell like you
know you the police ask you questions
you can remain silent and as soon as I
said that she was like don't you [__]
tell me
if you don't tell me what to say like if
you do I would say whatever I wanted I
was like sorry just please you dot me
and then take me down
like to you know to be a mother to you
oh yeah yeah it's pretty bad like the
amount of like when I was uh helping uh
yeah no no it's completely true yeah
that's very reasonable just the amount
of things to fix in that house that was
just like I don't even remember I shot
through that wall because you just shoot
through walls yeah and I'm like how my I
just my mum would beat me
[Music]
she would kill me if I was firing holes
paper you put glue and you put it on the
wall and then she finds out three years
later
when she leans against the wall
yeah yeah she did watch him then the
thing is you spent all your life kind of
micro dosing her on I'm like on
dangerous things and at least now you're
making money from it so it's kind of
like oh I guess my son's got a job
what do you even think about all this
[__] well I'm lucky that my mum is very
supportive of all of it and was kind of
like she had a job that she hated she
was an accountant so I guess in her
opinion she was like just be anything
besides an account please see when the
literal opposite
so before you made this your job but how
did your mom react to you [__] doing
all the [__] as a kid oh so I think as a
kid I was just hiding it a lot oh I'm
just trying like that is the Strat
sneaking out then doing it like after
school or would take days off just skip
school to go do that right
um
actually crazy this is not normal
but I'm making money from McConnell yeah
either way it up yeah he would have
become famous either from YouTube or he
would have just been a terrorist this is
the storyline like what if you you were
doing this but you were 15 years younger
like 15 years before there was no
YouTubers in Outlet you would have just
been like all right guys Isis
you know I I was talking to um a guy
that was in swat I was doing I forgot
what I was doing I was doing some job
before YouTube and he said to me
he was just like you remind me exactly
of the of all the guys that get caught
making meth yeah
probably that's probably what you do
before you do yeah yeah
oh my gosh that's like the second one
she was a Nigel Nigel was like that
Nigel's like meth is rookie I've asked
him so many times I'm like please Nigel
like make math
yeah
he could like I made meth out of cotton
candy or like you know
we asked him about it he was like no no
it's too easy yeah it's pretty easy it's
not exciting I'm gonna make uranium yeah
yeah yeah she's talking about uranium
and stuff you're like this sounds bad
yeah and it also seems like you get the
authorities calling you for like the
weirdest things because he got one chord
in him like the government side like
looking into him for a uh I think it's
like a test tube or something right it's
like a specific type of tube that you
would commonly use for making that yeah
um but it's like test tube and [__]
tampon gun sounds like the government
doesn't at least in when Canada where he
was like the government doesn't regulate
the really [__] crazy stuff it's like
no one should be able to get this anyway
yeah so there wasn't a lot of Regulation
around like uranium yeah who the [__]
can get uranium like you shouldn't be
able to get it so like why like we just
they just didn't think about making
rules No One's Gonna enrich uranium even
if you get the uranium you can't you
can't yeah
I'm doing uh
you want to make uh like this
I want us to do this video still
okay okay
there's got to have been a video where
you were concerned or you're like you
this is too much yeah I don't want him
doing any videos
looked like terrifying yeah that was
really bad that's probably the one where
it's the noise and the kind of like I
don't know what it was like the
reverberation in the room of just like
and then that getting faster it was like
the dumbest thing ever because you you
had the ceiling fan with machetes that
were spinning at only a speed that I can
imagine so and then as your defense you
I have this tiny piece of plywood that
was underneath and you're underneath it
and I'm like this even if it hit this
it's gonna go right it would go right
through it what are you doing you stand
in front of it and just go like all
right let's see
my logic was that because it was
spinning at high speed and it was above
me it would almost be impossible how
does the blade get down it could bounce
off something yeah bounce but then the
speed would be taken out of it
it would be a lot but I was like it
would fly through one of the walls or
the garage wall where my brothers were
standing so I think I think Alex is like
a living example of what is it was it
survivor bias or whatever
all these things that should have killed
him and he just assumes that
everything's safe now
oh my God don't say this I'm gonna die
now yeah
I tell him every day oh my God
has there ever been a video you came up
with where it's just like no this would
actually kill me if I tried to do it
yeah some so after I made the I made a
video uh where I made a Jacob's Ladder
which is where you got a bunch of
microwave um Transformers hook them
together and you create incredibly high
voltage because you're like you're doing
it parallel right yeah you're doing it
yeah I'm playing with a dumb amount of
amps so much that it would kill you
instantly well yeah that's what kills
you yeah I don't know and then I wanted
to make some more videos with um
electricity one of them was doing this
thing forgotten the exact name now but
it's called like lithographic art
and it goes like yeah create cool
patterns I wanted to to do some cool
versions of that yeah
um and then I was like no it's just not
worth it how far did you get into the
video before your life oh I had made all
of it except for for actually doing the
art and I was like no I should it's not
that interesting and it's not worth the
risk so that's why it was kind of like
if it was interesting enough I probably
would have done it it didn't explode
doesn't go boom I think boy boy though
has some good better examples of stuff
where we're like can we just yeah
because you it's got it I mean it's a
different yeah yeah yeah yeah it's just
Society is this acceptable Society yeah
yeah will my body survive yeah yeah yeah
you're constantly putting everything on
the line yeah yeah yeah well with boy
boy we had it we were seriously
considering going to Afghanistan to film
with the Taliban yeah
oh my God
recently what the [__] as soon as as
soon as America pulled out we're like no
more war this is the time
we'll like we'll go talk to the Taliban
see what's happening so what do you like
every single country Collective like do
not go through everything we cannot help
you if you go there that's what they
said about North Korea and So like
um
you could just tell the Taliban hey
here's all my details
um
[Music]
literally a couple of weeks ago when a
guy got kidnapped YouTubers got taken
hostage by the time yeah that was when
we're like the British guy yeah I think
British guy did not bowled in bankrupt
no he was Lord
after the other guy the guy who bought
one of those okay this this dude was
[__] weird
it's like a 4chan kid who yeah he bought
one of those shitty established titles
scam things and somehow actually managed
to convince his bank to put Lord that's
why he's lost he went around actually
like because then his bank had done it
so it's really easy to get everyone else
to recognize the Lord thing yeah and
then he went to Afghanistan and was
vlogging and then it was like a whole
[__] situation he was just unhinged yeah
it was clearly yeah come to me everybody
let's see we do it in the non on here
yeah we could be the normal ones he
clearly was just mental illness just in
Afghanistan yeah he seemed a bit of like
a psychotic episode turned into a
YouTube yeah like he clearly had like
needed some attention and it took it to
an extreme level and he was just hanging
around like vlogging when he was with
the Taliban yeah because he already had
a video out and we saw that and we're
like oh this is we can do this this is
easy and it turns out because pushed him
too far and that's the thing it's you
don't know until you're there and
there's there's a lot of different
factions and infighting whatever yeah at
the end of the day like what do you like
I mean from a from a um what is the what
would you get out of it like what would
you no I don't think because it's not
like we love the talents
are you actually getting anything out of
this or is it just because like you're
like you know it's like I don't know
what we're getting out of it but [__]
what's the angle well I think I think
yeah I mean we usually have a vaguely
like where where we have a lot of
opinions on the wall like I think it was
a horrible thing yeah yeah um and I
guess just going there is like a gimmick
and then we've got an excuse to talk
about it no literally like Afghanistan
for a bit this is a great YouTube
thumbnail like we joined the Taliban or
something and I was like what and then
you watch it and then you see like our
whole spiel about the Afghan war and
then yeah between people into this
Sunday
yeah
he's a freak dude yeah he's just weird
so this YouTuber that got kidnapped what
what happened is he still I think he
might still be kidnapped violent have we
not heard about this I don't know he's
barely a YouTuber yeah he's got nothing
yeah
I think when it's like it's like that
kind of character it makes it worse when
you give that there's going on yeah yeah
you're enabling him whenever you're
talking about what he's doing yeah I
mean but it's like it's one of those
things that when you're I guess it comes
up and it's relevant now but it's like
you don't want to give this [__] dude
attention because it's exactly what he
[__] wants yeah but I think he was
trying to push it like we make jokes I
think we we still try to do things that
are relatively safe yeah but he really
did just push it a lot where he was like
what did you want here what was your end
goal I think you can go to some of these
countries if you have a local fixer yeah
but I think he literally was just she
just [__] no show up there running
around just going around doing whatever
you want I mean you know yeah a lot of
the time you do need a fixer which is
the hard part I think yeah often
YouTubers who do go to these places
don't show that they have a fixer or not
yeah yeah they're like oh yeah I found
this all out where it's like some dude
has literally got you on a leash being
like yes it's literally saving your life
needs something to do it alone I've got
money yeah yeah um yeah it's pretty
crazy yeah aside from Afghanistan as and
beaten been any other videos I just feel
like you want to go to Warzone yeah yeah
you're doing like real life journalism
now like straight up yeah it's pretty
cool it's yeah it's like you guys are
really going out there and and Josh
documenting this stuff but also it's so
sarcastic and so downplayed that it
almost feels like this is unreal yeah
that's that's the whole thing because I
find I don't know personally that I mean
there are other people that do some kind
of Journalism but like I just find it so
boring when they're not if you're not
making jokes it's like who are you even
you're talking to people who are
interested in the news who already know
all this [__] yeah like if you're making
jokes it's like you're actually talking
to people who who aren't going to listen
to any of this you know like we wouldn't
otherwise listen to anything yeah but um
to answer your question it's kind of
it's kind of we're gonna sound super
dodgy but there are places that we
wanted to go that we still want to go
that we can't talk about because if we
tell you then we'll we'll be stopped
from going there
yeah we shouldn't even say that much
[__] Australian government you're
leaving yeah yeah please stop please go
to a nice place
oh my God how long are you until you
guys want to watch this oh well I found
someone released on Twitter someone that
works at a security
Expo or something like that or just
worked in government surveillance or
security released a took a photo of a
slideshow that was playing in a security
conference which was a threat assessment
of one of my videos and had like a
rating it was the video where I I used
drones to drop metal darts from 200
meters and showed that you could Pierce
a car and be fairly accurate with them
and then someone did a assessment on it
was like security threat it wasn't that
high it was like a four out of ten four
hours
you had a crazy one from that video
because someone used exactly the same
mechanism that was scary in the war in
Ukraine someone sent me a video and it
was like the same I mean it's a pretty
simple concept it was just drone takes
up something drops it never drops it
using the the light the same yeah it was
weird because I used um because mavic
doesn't have like a trigger mechanism or
way to trigger anything except for you
can turn on and off a light yeah so I
just had an Arduino which had a light
sensor so when you when you turn on the
light then that triggers a a Servo motor
which opens the arm and you can drop
something and then someone used it like
exactly the same and even like it just
looked like it was the same the same um
3D printed file and I was like oh that's
a bit I used to drop grenades in on
Russians or maybe Russians on Ukrainian
so you think maybe they got inspiration
from your video or I mean I I don't know
I think it's a pretty dropping stuff
from this yeah yeah yeah pretty common
concept but it was a bit like oh that's
right the video has eight million views
so there's a chance that someone's
watching oh my God God great yeah you
should take credit for your good work
yeah wouldn't have happened if it wasn't
for you
I'm responsible yeah oh God instead of
sneaking into an arms convention we'll
just be we ran in arms
we started an armed convention right now
what a character development you went
from just blowing [__] up in your yard
or whatever to now I guess making uh
everyone stop somewhere right yeah
did you I got both of your guys's ideas
are like what's wrong with you both